[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
hannity on a friday night our colleague
shannon breme he's been pretty busy
lately but somehow in between her live
coverage of the ukraine invasion on fox
news at night and her daytime analysis
of the supreme court hearings she
somehow found some time to write a
fantastic new book that's available
right now sean caught up with her to
talk all about it take a look
now fox news at night host shannon breme
has a fascinating new book taking
readers on a journey through the lives
of biblical women detailing their
heroism their sacrifices and the
connection between faith and family and
here to explain more author of the
mothers and daughters of the bible speak
it hits the shelves on march the 29th
it's on amazon.com we'll put a link on
hannity.com uh our colleague our friend
shannon bream is with us shannon good to
see you how are you
great to see you sean i'm good
you know i i look at what's going on in
ukraine and
you see the vital role
that women are playing for example
they're taking the children to
border countries they're taking the the
brunt of taking care of the family
and the men are going back and fighting
in world war ii very similar story as my
dad fought in the pacific for four years
but if it weren't for
everyone else including every
able-bodied man and woman working in
factories and building the munitions
needed on in the field of battle they
wouldn't they wouldn't have been able to
win
um it's the same those lessons are
reinforced in this book
yeah they are because we see over time
that women have been called to step in
many times to be brave to be bold men of
course throughout the bible too but we
see the strength of mothers and their
commitment to their children the book
starts with the story of jochebed who's
the mother of moses and her daughter
miriam they're the mother-daughter pair
they kick us off and they were so brave
because you think about it jacobed was a
slave woman she was oppressed and there
was an order that went out that every
mother that had a baby if it was a boy
it immediately had to be killed and she
said no i mean she had no choice in
control in her life but she made that
very brave choice and she and her
daughter together saved and hid moses
until he was able to go on to a destiny
that changed the world well explain the
rest of that story and what they did
with the baby moses and how he was
literally putting like a mini boat and
sent down the roof yes
exactly and the crazy thing is he was
supposed to be thrown into the river to
be killed the river nile that's where
all the baby boys were supposed to go
but after she hit him for some months
jacob said all right i gotta have faith
and send this little boy out she created
like a little mini ark for him a little
waterproof bin that she put him in and
miriam was the one who stood there on
the banks and watched to see what would
happen to moses and pharaoh's daughter
happened to be there bathing and and
happened upon him heard this baby crying
and we're told in the bible she had
great compassion for him so little
miriam risks her life as a little slave
girl steps up and says oh by the way if
you need a hebrew woman to um nurse him
until you're ready to take him into the
palace because she wanted to adopt him i
know just the woman so miriam was able
to run home and tell jacob moses is
going to come home to us she was able to
raise him for two or three years then
before he went off to the palace and of
course his ultimate destiny was to save
the entire nation of israel now the the
the book goes into great depth and
detail about the women in the bible
are there a top three that come to mind
that really inspired you the most
yeah i think of course the story about
jacob and miriam is a big one but esther
too we think about her
being
in the perfect place at the perfect time
god obviously put her there and you know
the verse that for such a time as this
she was told when she was she was
struggling to be courageous in that
moment when she had to step up and and
be the one to save the jewish people you
know if you don't do this uh somebody
else will be called into action but
maybe for such a time as this you were
put there and she was and again she was
a great savior and of course mary the
mother of jesus in the new testament we
see and and like these mothers in
ukraine mary was on the run with baby
jesus at one point when god came to her
and to joseph actually in a dream and
said you got to go right now king
herod's trying to kill your baby so i
think about her in this dusty um you
know trip with no planning grabbing
everything in the middle of the night
with a toddler and setting out trying to
find safety and ending up in a strange
land with no family and no friends and
that's what these brave mothers of
ukraine are modeling for us to do and so
you know god was in those stories
centuries ago and he sees the plight and
the suffering today the book is called
the mothers and daughters of the bible
speak lessons on faith from nine
biblical families it's in bookstores as
of march 29th it's on amazon.com you can
get your copy now uh shannon i know you
had a great bestseller last time this
will be a big best seller as well uh
thank you for sharing it with us
thank you sean
thank you sean and congrats shannon on
the book and and next week there will be
a fox nation special on shannon's book
it's called the mothers and daughters of
the bible speak lessons on faith from
nine biblical families make sure to
check that out hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else